la question running du jour faut-il
courir en forêt ce que c'est une bonne
idée
[Musique]
assurément non c'est pas une bonne idée
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi moi que
vous connaissiez le massif ça représente
que des dangers d'une part vous pouvez
vous perdre ensuite le terrain est
extrêmement meubles ça veut dire
accidents possibles blessures
il faut savoir qu'au milieu d'une forêt
eh bien il n'y a pas grand monde pour
venir vous chercher et les secours vont
mettre du temps en tout cas vous
localiser le téléphone passe pas
toujours
ensuite il ya le problème est qu'à
métérologie le vont par exemple les
chutes d'arbres les chutes de branches
là aussi grand danger qui les
rencontrent parfois avec certains
animaux je peux vous en parler ça m'est
déjà arrivé de me faire courser par un
sanglier
voilà pour ces petits conseils non non
vous mieux courir là où il ya du monde
pas isolée en plein milieu des bois
bonne journée
à bientôt pour un nouveau conseil
[Musique]